so i'm switching from slow chests
to hyper aggressive chests
let's try and win this tournament
i'm late joining
this is an hour long tournament
yeah 57 minutes
i've joined 12 minutes late
some people have 11 points
i'll try and be strategic with
berserking probably anyone rated below
2000 i'll be against
queen e2 is very typical reinforcing the
pawn
bishop g4 i'll play an f3
so if d4 even though it looks aggressive
gaining space
allows for knight a4 and i can play very
positionally
oh my watch just told me i broke my
activity goal
for the day
oh it just told me that i i achieved my
stand goal
that's so weird i've been sitting the
whole time i think
okay let's castle
king
yeah just getting off the diagonal
smelling some ideas of taking but
let's be solid d3
oh yeah i meant to play e5 e5 was such
an easy move happy new year guys
here happy 15th subversary to me
i couldn't help myself from winning
connect for
such a weird mouse slip
i'll take with rook
oh thank you pt player happy new year
and subversary
appointment wants to smother mate me
that's not going to happen
many things defending
this night is weirdly stuck
and i hear i'll take with bishop
and right here probably bishop g5
a leader has 16 points
uh that's a good move
to take with them no if i took with
queen or rook there is knight f2
[Music]
okay now knight of six bishop g5 queen
b2
so it looks a little bit slow but
rook b1
is covering the b-pawn want to activate
the bishop
and now i want to take play this listen
mate
d6 was hanging for a moment
black is giving me some mercy
if i was in france and my opponent gave
me mercy
i would say mercy
okay so the queen and knight are
attacked
the queen's still attacked and now tied
down to defending the knights
oh no black's queen
where's my mate
wait a minute this is more efficient
okay got the first one down
trying to break into the top hundred
yeah so john bartholomew also streaming
maybe also late joined
not seeing him in the top
50 oh top okay top 41.
i'll deserve again
play
stafford gambit time staff for gamut
time
let's punish the staff right now no
mercy
so h4 is a h5 is a move that i like to
play
um there is an interesting move knight
g4 here takes in queen h4
but these two moves are the
main options i'll play c3
play like the main refutation line
bishop g4 never seen this move before
i think i can just get away with
expanding it's one of the issues with
the stafford is sometimes
if white can get the immaculate pawn
center
[Music]
it's hard for black to do much of course
black wants to create chaos
now i can play bishop g5
yeah recently i've been less
lenient with
dealing with the stafford
just trying to punish it to the maximum
there is still potential for
connect a checkmate
let's keep my pawns
also no reason to take the knight
because it is pinned
trying to trap my bishop
or trappa not my bishop
soon to be my bishop ah
okay let's
actually let's win the bishop first
happy new year is this gonna happen take
some mate
ah it's not happening
but made is
lightly coming very soon
where is it
yeah everything's crumbling for black
whoa
it's good news everyone from sweden
happy new year
thanks so much
5 000 bits
where's my mate
oh there's a funny line okay just for
those in sweden
oh no my queen
ah black doesn't even take my queen
ah
so the the funny line was takes and then
bishop a6
this isn't quite mates but after queen
b7
[Music]
i i would probably just take and okay
soon to be mate
oh a new game started
playing cacmacos
uh
let's play oh no that's i should not
have berserks
okay but now i have to deal with my
my life decisions
the opponent is rated 23.25
i'm giving some slight timeouts
they're taking time in the opening
yeah so main line is knight f3 here here
and then
happy new year
everything will get better just hold on
tight
yeah let's hold on tight
try and avoid flagging i take this i
think i can
[Music]
because knight c3 there's bishop b4
i mean knight is pinned but
yeah this looks pretty stable
hey happy new year to ipsy
yeah it's already
way past midnight in germany
i take this
hey it's our raid it's fiona fionchetta
happy new year
thanks for the raid
shout out to fiona
hope you're doing well
if you're just joining i i'm playing the
hourly blitz arena
i latejoin the tournament i'm trying to
win it
i beserk this game kind of on accident
preventing knight b5
yeah happy new year to fiona
i don't think i saw fiona
in 2021
at least in real life
but maybe at some point we'll see each
other in 2022.
okay so i'm down about a minute
opponent is wanting to flag me
i have the bishop pair have the open
files
play this move
redevelop the bishop to b7
wow play this move
i mean the hope is takes takes remove
the knights and then win the bishop
easier said than done
rook d1
i'm not sure if that works actually
after rook d1 takes takes takes takes
and c7 is weak
and there's one check to check but b3
kills all my fun
so i'm probably better off after rook d1
playing bishop b6
uh same thing here i think
that's very similar
and now rook hd1 we probably trade
opponent
opponent blunder
not quite 95 is really annoying
looking at f8
i wanted to take the bishop at 97.
wasn't good for me
at least we're getting into some time
scramble situation
cones getting low on time
oh no my pawn
okay rookie three so we're invading the
om of white
and york g2
active rook versus passive rook
my pawns should be on dark squares
along with my king probably
covering the infiltration squares
check
i think i'm almost winning a pawn
whoa
was this move
i'm almost meeting i was fighting maiden
one
i don't think white can oh white has
this move
maybe white's somehow defending
okay i should win that
hey i passed finn's
yeah finns is john bartholomew also
streaming
11 tournament points leader has 29 man
will you be in berlin in january
uh
no i won't
but i'll likely be in london and then
gibraltar
okay opponent also berserking
i really need to berserk almost every
game to catch up
yeah playing a closed sicilian
pretty typical setup so far
[Music]
h5 of h3
and preventing any knight g4 shenanigans
some idea c3 at some point
c4 is also an idea
so block's not casting queen sign
and question how to get to the king
uh d4
i'll play king h2 first
trying to make some improvements i'm
allowing this in this
it's hard to really crack the
[Music]
position challenge the b file
wow okay
castling i think was a big mistake
it allows for the
opening of the king side
shift over
now it's all about attacking
f5 ideas
okay gonna have some fun here these
pieces aren't really defending the king
f6
oh there's almost a funny mate
king g3
it involves ono my queen
i need to unleash the rook
i'm threatening queen h8 now
[Music]
hey oh no my queen
so this comes with double check
king has to move back and then i mate
okay that was a feel-good finish
moving on top 10.
this player has 37 points that's crazy
not even berserking every game
[Music]
okay playing wild strawberry
uh
maybe two knights
knights tango
okay i'll play d5
be hard to play aggressively against uh
this opening
at least from very early on
so i'm playing my main thing
no gambits here
uh bishop f4 let's play this move
a6 is not a main line
uh
but it has idea of
developing nicely on the queen side
i think maybe i could have played c5
there
ac5 first
this is a typical structure for black
against the queen's gambit
hey it's wander thanks for the raid
okay now i definitely have to do battle
rail
for those that don't know wander
a prolific scrabble streamer
one of the best
scrabble players in the world
and in our hearts
hope you had a good stream happy new
year
shout out to wander15
yeah i was saying earlier that i still
don't fully know the rules of the game
but it looks really fun
i love the concept of combining
[Music]
like a word game and battle royale
anyway for those just joining i'm about
midway through
the hourly blitz arena i did late join
this tournament i'm trying to win it
it's gonna be tough though
eighth place leader is really pulling
away from everyone
i just got to take one game at a time
i think queen a8
creating the battery
always draw back to f8 if i need to
mine's just going for trades
i mean i'm winning a pawn
i might as well do this this
a6 might be weak in the end
okay so i win this
you're hitting the bishop
i have some back rank issues probably
have to play g5
that's a good move i have this hitting
b2
this doesn't feel so clear
okay so i make a looft
i just want to simplify a bit
19 seconds
so the pawn goes a7 then my king has to
ensure it's not checkable from the rook
okay so here we trade so this actually
transforms the position a lot
the c pawn is going to run
and get behind it
i think i can win it now
[Music]
might see like rook h8 at some point
even that
oh no
one missed a win
ah
i just had to make one more move
oh
good game
that's what i got for berserking
point zero four
[Music]
okay ah
i'll turn on the hurry monitor how about
that's so sad
i was so close too
okay let's take all my anger out against
this opponent
by not hanging a knight
i think i'll play bishop d2 threatening
this
there's bishop c5
waiting for g6 so i can access
h6
there we go
i'll play this move
okay we have a funny position
my knight is fiend caddo on g7
where's my win though
[Music]
g5
g5 just trapped my pieces
maybe this move
getting the knight
if i take
move back
so g5 i sack
queen f3 incoming
bishop g4 i just take it
it's still a little bit murky but i
think rook g7
i take on f6 king f8 bishop h6
and there's no good way to defend f6
just no way possible
i could probably pre-move this if i want
i'm not sure whether to take next with
queen or bishop
oh that's really close to mate
get the bishop ready
here we go
okay no time to waste
i think i still have a little bit of
hope
but
the leader has 50 tournament points
that's insane
i just need to win games super super
quickly
it shouldn't be too difficult to catch
up to second
okay playing block redeemer
i'm actually going for the rider gambit
okay this is a free pawn i believe
bishop ca i don't think was great or
bishop's g4 wasn't great
maybe knight b5
this is looking very appetizing
okay so this one's a queen
if jesus never mind
okay we'll pin the knight
some idea this and this
or even just taking
simplifying down
when the knight
so i'm up a full queen and
a pawn
and now the exchange
now another pawn
okay that was pleasant
blackmart deemer ridering abbott
it pays off
to break back into the 2600 club too
like this person who beat me earlier
or no
i won earlier but okay double berserking
hello
hello
super sugar
that was a sweet resub
okay i just want to castle and then
attack
is f3 f3 might be possible
i figure it's a really good move please
play it
f3 is actually a really bad move because
queen h4
uh
oh no my bishop
opponent i can't reverse stream snipe
you see through my plans
i'll go for f5
oh finns and i are tired 22 points
apiece
yeah it's a weird position because
there's four attackers
let's play this move
i might be losing a pawn
maybe there's comp
other rook will come in
g3
[Music]
or f3 i was thinking about sagging on g3
so now the bishop's pinned
in two directions
takes
how to do this
c5
okay idea to take in bishop f3
ah good move
okay i'll try and win the old-fashioned
way
using the clock as a weapon
opponents fighting
where's the wind
very clever
okay won the game
good fight for my opponent though
no time to
waste playing the player in third place
gotta try it
oh my knight oh no
oh no
it's been a while since i've tried this
one
bishop g5
i think it's okay
my knight's still hanging
please take it
and now i take
q6 getting some comp
because these two pawns are attacked now
it's actually turning into a reasonable
type of gambit
f6 first
i can take
oh first place still has 50 points
a good sign
in this first idea g5 h4
95
hey it's tristan buying merch thanks so
much shout out to talmage middle school
chess club oh hey hey nice
hello to tall madge middle school chess
club
i trap the bishop
actually let's just take and get the
bishop hair
i love your london videos oh do you
recommend going queen b3 if opponent
moves c8 bishop early i can often catch
your opponents off guard this way
yeah that's the general rule the b pawns
undefended than queen b3 can be
useful idea
okay threatening to trap the bishop
and just go for the kingside attack
rook h7
that's a good move
f5
yeah losing on my bishop pair might be
winning the pawn though
[Music]
we'll play h3
not quite winning d3 because there's
rook c1
okay at least i have c4
i want to play this
play this move
might be tricky to win
the stacked exchange
should be winning the 16 seconds
get the king to d4
restricting white's king
yeah it's
i think it's still winning though
the rook doesn't have time to take the
pawn and bishop c4
there's a mate
there's a mate okay
that was a close one
no time to waste
oh this person lost a game oh but
they're still playing
okay 32 points 13 minutes left
on another berserk streak
playing
alexander morizevich
a scary
[Music]
okay name gonna play a setup with
queenside castling
one of the more aggressive ways to play
this position
[Music]
so get the queen
black queen aligned with my rook
there's a d3 knight c6 or knight a6 like
play never mind
uh play h4
yeah just going all out for the attack
here
yolo
thinking d5 at some point i have to get
rid of this knight somehow
okay save the bishop
i want to play a3 next
and this could backfire playing very
kind of risky chess
living on the edge
assuming that i moves i take on d5
a tricky position
the dream is to
remove the knight play bishop jievan
mate
i thought i really wanted to suck but
i think it was too risky
in g4 here
along knight b3
also that move
and now at least the g file's open
i don't mind queen g4
and knight's been attacked by the pawn
for a long time
i missed fish about five
oh bishop f5 there's knight b3
also missed just a free knight but okay
the queen's attacked
knight will be free next move
so now if king takes bishop i discover
fork
if takes
oh i didn't see that move
uh let's just continue
double rooks
that was
kind of a messy game
i feel like i'm just trying to throw mud
at the opponent
e4 hitting the bishop and maybe this
rook
threatening this to win the rook
when it defends let's play king c2
yeah my tactics don't work here
i want to take here
this is really really risky
king is experiencing the world
[Music]
i'm learning takes takes etc
there's queen d5 but then takes takes
okay this is happening
okay now it looks pretty good because
i'm threatening made in one
[Music]
there's rook g7 but
now it should be winning
all the risks kind of paid off
i think i made a lot of blunders this
game though
a leader still has 50 points wow
take on f7
[Music]
and that's mate
okay third place
berserk playing the strawberry again who
beat me earlier
ah this game from earlier came down to
the wire
opponent in berserk back
try and get revenge
happy new year to hyper flu and rmt
this line
unless you nagmansen
might see a nagminson
magnus and i take on c3 and play d5
this is also playable
queen d7 is the move for some reason
should be seven
wait i think i can take with queen
looks weird but
i have to be courageous sometimes
i also want to develop my bishop
maybe this move
it's also queen h4
[Music]
rook t8 maybe
i'm trying to improve with tempo
yeah i didn't want to play this and run
into knight c5
rook t1 would be a really nice gift
not gonna happen because there's too
many ways for me to win material
if knight has six i just take it
might be threatening to take take in
rook d2
then there's rook c4 c6
objectively okay let's just go into this
king f8 first
rookie choose a safe move
playing this for a win now
[Music]
it's gonna be hard to play for a win
though
[Music]
let's start working on the edges
interesting
now my king has an entry point
looks tied down to the b pawn
i allowed rook d7 but i have rook c5
preventing root e7 now
it's still like objectively just equal
[Music]
g4 was kind of a risk from
light wow
[Music]
go play b5
trying to damage the structure
i'm having flashbacks from the last time
i played wild strawberry
might be a very venomous strawberry
uh
e3 maybe
a3 weakening
c6
kind of trapping in my own rook
i didn't know what else to do
[Music]
so rook d7 i play king eight
oh no
i think white missed a cool idea
now i'm okay still
check
i went upon
i kind of plundered there
happy new year from europe oh thank you
[Music]
happy new year to europe
i'm gonna win this pawn
do
let's go okay
sweet sweet revenge
so 42 points the leader is losing all
their games
i need to win two games and four minutes
to have any chance
it's possible i think
i need a game to start immediately
oh the heart rate
uh hurrying on
browser of course
hey let's look there okay no time to
turn turn the heart rate on
i don't know why i'm playing the london
let's play h4h5
okay trying to play as aggressively as
possible here
apart from playing the london opening
you target g6 queen c2
i just want to take on g6
if not fade i take okay let's take here
i need to take and then queen g6
check
rook is now hanging
let's go okay
one more game come on
after berserk
another choice
one's not because working back
now let's play knight's tango
okay i have to play in some king's
indian style like d65
well it looks passive but
okay e5 probably
my d495
h5
i hang upon takes takes
might be okay
i should play this move at some point
and there might be even knight d3 ideas
a
and this move
with knight b1
use this move play a6
just gotta go all out
what else to do
this is super super risky
i'm trying to win the tournament
opponent took with bishop
unexpected
and checking
and knight f3 there
i should have played knight f3
still threatening knight f3
really close to winning
i missed
i still have it
not meeting though
now the rook is hanging
oh it's so close
oh this is completely winning now
oh no is it
i think it is
oh no i hung a queen
[Music]
i'm just losing now
and there goes my tournament
oh i'm not going to win this game
that's so sad
please wonder nate
oh
[Music]
my beautiful position
[Music]
oh
i was so close too
[Music]
i have 18 seconds left
and no queen
what to do
so close
i got so close at first
i missed you xoxo oh xoxo
missed you two toxic banana party
what to do
oh my king
did i miss force made in this game
i felt really really close
ah i have knight d4
i panicked i have knight d4 here
like v4 he's just winning
happy new year from yorkshire 94's
fourth major four for black wow
because uh the threats are too strong
like i saw this and this but knight d4
is supported by the pawn
i thought i could maybe survive but then
i got forked
did you see john's rosen trap
should i try a rosen trap
i'm gonna try to set it up ah rook b3
[Laughter]
oh i'm so proud good job